the question is
what is something you changed your
opinion about in the past
few years thank you for everything
you're doing love from brussels
i love belgium thank you for that
question and the kind words i changed my
mind on a lot of things and i changed my
mind all the time
i'm in a constant flux i'm constantly
learning
i guess my mind is the quantum
mechanical system but i can mention a
few things that have been
stable big shifts in my
thinking at least over the past year or
two
especially related to the podcast so on
the topic of uh
psychedelics i've always found those
fascinating
what i've changed my mind over the past
couple years is a
hopeful message i think that uh
psychedelics can actually
enter the realm of science and that
there's a bunch of places that are
starting to conduct large-scale
research studies on psychedelics and
that's really exciting to me
because i have a sense that that's just
another perspective
into the world of neuroscience that will
help us understand the way the mind
works
and potentially how to engineer
different
aspects of what makes the human mind so
special
in our artificial intelligence systems
on the topic of social media i've
changed my mind over the past two years
i always felt that it had a bunch of
complicated bad influences on society
but they were balanced with a lot of
positive effects that
uh build community they give people a
voice all those kinds of things
more and more i'm starting to think that
the
possible set of destructive trajectories
that
social media can take human civilization
is uh much wider much more destructive
than i accounted for
so it's something that i worry about you
know in the space of existential risk of
artificial intelligence that people talk
about
i think my mind more and more over the
past two years has been focused on
social media as the greatest threat of
artificial intelligence
i also think it's the greatest set of
possibilities so
what i want to say is it's the set of
trajectories is wider than i expected
the set of possible trajectories and
society might go
as driven by managed by directed by
our platforms hence it's been something
that
i've been working on to see if i can
help
the biggest thing i probably changed my
mind on is that
extraterrestrial life intelligence
consciousness is worthy of serious
scientific investigation
it's similar how i felt before about
consciousness human consciousness
is that we lack the tools and we're very
early in our ability to explore
to understand to engineer consciousness
and the same with extraterrestrial life
the tools are very crude in terms of the
study efforts of trying to communicate
with far away
civilizations and also the the listening
then there's the detection and uh far
away exoplanets and
whether they're habitable in life forms
on those planets
also the hundreds of thousands of
reports of ufo sightings
actually getting some high resolution
sensory data around that
so we're in the very early days of any
of that kind of understanding
but what i've changed my mind on
rather what i've come to understand is
closing my mind closing the mind of
other scientists
to these fields of consciousness and
extraterrestrial life
prevents us from actually discovering
new things
basically what happens when you close
your mind to these fascinating
inspiring mysterious uh
spaces of exploration
you leave the exploration of these
topics the people that are not
well equipped to explore them they're
just curious minds
and by the way those curious minds are
magical
and they're inspiring and i'm one such
curious mind
but the rigors of science the tools of
science the funding of science can uh
can crack these wide open and give us
better data
better understanding inspired totally
new ways of thinking about consciousness
about extraterrestrial life
have entire paradigm shifts of the way
we approach
our understanding of intelligence of
life forms in general
and there's a lot of things that kind of
opened my eyes
to this fascinating world the david's
favorite conversation of
the pilot that uh saw the
tic tac ufo the was just recent
more more conversation but that was in
2017 i remember seeing
avi loeb's thoughts about ammo when it
first came out and
and even just thinking about the drake
equation more seriously and think about
the different possibilities built into
the
uncertainty of the parameters just
open my eyes to the mystery and the
wonder
of the amazing universe we're in
and how little we know about it and so
i've definitely kind of become much
more intellectually open to the
exploration
of what extraterrestrial life might look
like
what are the ways we might be able to
communicate with it
how we might be able to understand it
what does it teach us about ourselves
and also importantly this very
fascinating psychological effect
of being open to these
mysteries that we know very little about
what does that do to the
actual productivity the
the creative output of an engineering
mind
that opening your mind in this way to
think outside
of the little box of things we
understand well
what does that do in terms of the things
you might be able to build
the ideas that might visit you
and result in you being able to build
something totally new
i think all of that changed my mind
about aliens that's why i've been having
conversations about
extraterrestrial life i'm of course very
careful walking down this line
because i am first and foremost a
scientist and engineer and i want to
stay in that world
but i really do want to cultivate an
open mind
and a child-like curiosity and i
generally hope to see that
in other scientists as well that's what
science is all about
i think incremental progress is
essential
for science but it has to be coupled
to that childlike wonder about the world
and and open-minded out-of-the-box
thinking the results in major paradigm
shift
that throw all those silly citations out
the window
and build totally new sciences totally
new approaches
that make everything we did in the
decades
past meaningless are actually
counterproductive
so they have to be coupled together
incremental progress
and first principles
deep thinking that results in paradigm
shifts
you